昨年、2人の若者がビットコインの旅を始めました。
1人は1日12時間、チャートを凝視し、あらゆる陽線を追いかけました。
しかし昨夜、たった一度の「クジラの罠（Whale
Trap）」が、彼の全資産を吹き飛ばしました。
もう1人の男はどうでしょう？
彼は家族と夕食を楽しみ、コーヒーを飲み、翌朝5000ドル
の利益と共に目覚めました。
この違いは運ではありません。
「システム」の差です。
1人は狩りをしており、もう1人は「防衛」をしていたのです。
多くのトレーダーが失敗するのは、トレードを「買うこと
」だと思っているからです。
違います。
トレードとは「罠に落ちないこと」なのです。
BTC市場において、あなたは常に機関投資家に狙われています。
盾を持たなければ、あなたの感情は最大の敵となります。
FOMO（取り残される恐怖）を感じて買いボタンを押した瞬
間、罠が作動します。
Trap Defence BTCは、すべてを変えます。
私たちのエンジンは、クジラが仕掛けた見えない罠を可視化します。
私たちが教えるのは、世界で最も強力なスキル、すなわち「時間の70パーセン
トを、あえて何もしない」という規律です。
あなたが動くときは、90パーセントの確信があるときだけです。
これは、ハイリスクな市場のための「高解像度な防衛策」です。
すべてを失うトレーダーにならないでください。
資産を守り抜く側になってください。
以下から、あなたの防衛プロトコルを起動してください。
アカデミーへようこそ。